[Music]
hello and welcome to two-year Hank and
John alright as John likes to call it
Dear John and Hank
it's an advised comedy podcast where we
give you do pious advice and dubious
comedy what I'll do do talk about the
Chipmunks yep apparently and and John
isn't here today
no so I am filling in and I am I'm
Katherine this is Katherine my wife
Katherine Hanks wife that's how you
designate me and do we also bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon though I don't know that
we're gonna get any AFC Wimbledon news
today are they doing anything
interesting
I bet sure maybe uh I just I often
Google Ligue 1 table and I see if AFC
Wimbledon is oh well I just did that
well that's good then it was the last
time I did it okay well there you go
well get therapy and they'll get there
at the end of the podcast we're gonna
talk about that yet but but then I asked
how you do in Katherine um Katherine is
okay I just noticed that my computer has
13 percent battery so I'm doing better
than my computer mmm but um I'm
currently growing a human yes outside of
my body now uh-huh
after having done it inside of my body
for don't let them tell you it's nine
months it's nine and a half sometimes
ten and it's draining let me tell you
yes literally the whole thing yeah is
just from stop you know talk you know
start to start to finish draining and
then there's the the person yeah they
come out and they still need you need
you literally I'm like you know I mean
it still subsist on your body yes it's
different yeah I wouldn't say I love it
you love him yes but the thing of like
having to be his only uh-huh it's weird
well it's going okay cuz he keeps
getting big
oh he's huge he's big he's big Oh which
is fine I am pleased and proud to be
doing it yeah I'm I guess enjoying it
because it's this crazy experience that
is mhm like nothing else
yeah but it is not easy
yeah and it is not 100% to joy all the
time you guys know this hall man there's
certain anyone tell you so many things
that you will read and we were off there
aren't the hall man so many things
you'll read that will make it seem like
some I don't know maybe this is the case
for some people that it is this like or
like almost like physically joyous thing
at every step of the way and maybe that
is the case for some people yeah but
those are like those people got to be
rare yeah I think it's the minority and
I think that I think that it's hard and
I think that that's fine like total I
just I I'm not I'm don't like the idea
that like people try to sugarcoat it
well yeah I mean you don't do things cuz
they're easy right all the things that
are worth doing are hard well I mean
whatever
except for Patrick's question if we just
want to jump right in sure this Patrick
has a great question
yeah it has a great a great take on what
I just said maybe not being true Patrick
says dear Hank and John yesterday I
received in the email that has similar
semi troubling Spotify it sent me a year
in review email that revealed several
facts about my consumption of music on
their platform the main fact being that
I spent over 27,000 minutes listening to
music in 2016 that's 19 full days I
can't help thinking that while I enjoyed
the music I listened to immensely it has
been a waste of time
again I would like to say that I love
the music that I listened to yet I can't
help but think that of all the things
that I could have done how much time I
could have spent with friends or how
much I could have written I think what
I'm asking is how can I for the new year
try to put more thought into what I
consume or find a better balance
well I wouldn't before I answer that
question I want to go back and say that
if you find joy in a thing yeah
wonderful ha so know that there are many
things that are worth doing that are not
hard just because you enjoyed them
yeah um also like nineteen days isn't
that large a portion of the year yeah I
mean I spent nineteen days doing boring
her things than listening to music
probably yeah probably I wish that I
spent time that much time listening to
music I I love listening to music myself
I think that it gets you in touch with
like a human thing that is very sort of
visceral and like I miss having the time
to spend lots of time listen to music
and discovering new music and also I
will say that Patrick you probably did
other things while you were listening to
that music well that's my question like
it when he's listening to music is he
just listening to music even though you
I feel like that is not what most
people's experience of listening to
music is even if you are just sitting
there with your headphones on sure and
that's all you're doing you slick your
eyes close get blindfold on yeah
headphones on yeah
your submersed in a tank you can sense
no other sensations you're still doing
other stuff sure like your listen to
that music you're thinking about your
life yeah it's got affective
contemplative time yes and it's it's uh
right it's giving you time to become a
more of a person yeah whatever
I don't think you should be worried
about this at all
so I mean you say that for the new year
I want to try to put more thought into
what I consume or or find a better
balance again Kathryn said 19 days in
365 isn't actually all that many yeah
that's not I don't think yeah they're
having a trouble with balance no but but
I do think that you should put thought
into into what you consume and I also do
think that spending time creating stuff
is also really important a thing that I
can get trapped in sometimes is I can
consume a lot of content that's very
very good and I feel like I'll never
make anything that good and so I won't
even start
and forgetting that of course every
everybody who created something that I
really loved their first song they ever
wrote wasn't a masterwork
though with songwriting sometimes I feel
like it is that way like first song they
write I'm like what this is your first
album stop leave go away well it
probably wasn't the first song they
wrote though right they probably wrote
those songs in middle school that nobody
gets to hear oh man what I love to hear
yeah some juvenilia from like Adele and
right well at the same time like Taylor
Swift
what is she 14 she's right an amazing
stuff she's a child let's be honest um
anyway the thing about you know making
stuff is the more you do it the better
you are at it generally yeah or or at
least you'll find more joy in it or
you'll find a mark but you'll find a
better direction I think if you're
having a good time listening to music do
that do it definitely do that Patrick
have a good time all right we've got
another question it's from nobody I
didn't write down the name who says dear
Hank and John don't know who they are as
I was celebrating New Year's Eve with
some friends one of my friends said that
that they in quotation marks added a
leap second to the end of every year to
match up with the Earth's rotation which
is slowing down over time who is they is
there an international time society that
does that decides what time it is across
the world yes how would that decision
have been made yes this is a fantastic
question because you don't think about
the fact that somebody decides what time
it is this is important because it is
New Year's Day when we are recording
this yes well it also we should have
started the podcast by saying happy new
year it's the first podcast of 27th
probably should have started the podcast
by saying that happy new year it's the
first podcast of
noisemaker Apatow good that's good
all right well we got that done with but
yeah so there is a big plan this plan
very well there is the thing busy so who
do you think cares most in the whole
world what exact time it is I started up
ad you want to stop the stock market
they care uh but not as much as sort of
International Monetary Fund is that the
money people the money people are it's
not our abstract yeah okay it is then
give me a hint
it have to do with space silence
it's the satellite people oh yeah it's
it's okay
it's the the telecommunications people
oddly enough through the international
telecommunication union does a bunch of
different things they define a bunch of
different things they help create
standards for telecommunications in a
bunch of different ways but one of the
things that the International
Telecommunications Union does which is a
probably based in Geneva Switzerland
I'm guessing sure they decide what time
it is
and that is very important for things
like GPS for cell phone for cell phone
like when when the towers are gonna be
working and when the satellites are
gonna be working and and figuring out so
it's not so much about where the
satellites are in space and and it's
about where that you would need to know
exactly where they are
okay so it is so you need to know
whether any questions yes yes you know
where they are in time in space
so yeah they also divide up like the
bands of of you know radio frequencies
and stuff like that so there's this this
organization and they just days yeah
they are in Geneva Switzerland no
they're in Bern no they're in Geneva and
they have existed since 1865 and they're
kind of now part of the United Nations
and that's and it's sort of amazing to
me that like like
everybody agrees on that with nobody
nobody has a different time the way we
have different distances yeah yeah yeah
we have we have different years even but
we have the same time because it was a
relatively late addition to our like to
the metrics of the world quite kind of
though but like in China they have the
same time but it's not like actually
relevant depending on where they are
they have this well I mean depends on
who you are time might not be relevant
to you just out you mean I don't know I
I just it seems like I don't know it
seems I mean it's arbitrary obviously
but yes yeah it's totally arbitrary but
it's important to be able to keep
perfect time okay so what was the
question who are they who are they they
are the international telecommunication
union we all agree that's we are to to
allow those people to decide for us what
time it is
well because Italy yeah that's having
any idea that they exist right so I just
want to say thank you to the people of
the international telecommunication
union for doing all that hard work and
it is interesting because you always
hear like we are adding a second but
like who's we they they are them they
have done it indeed do you want to read
a question Katherine um yeah I'm looking
for one here's a question from Olivia my
family has an odd Christmas tradition of
putting a coconut under the tree that
originated when my grandmother was a
child
Monique we haven't replaced the coconut
for several years and simply store it
with our other decorations I was
wondering what happens to the milk
inside the coconut Oh
does it dry up as my mom guessed does it
turn into coconut cheese how would said
cheese taste
Oh God coconut cheese should we get a
new coconuts
I I you know I wish I knew the answer
this question but I certainly do not
I think it tries I didn't I did not do
any investigation into this question
well the work is gonna say it turns into
coconut cheese I mean coconut cheese it
is God Jesus definitely you should get a
new coconut I don't think so it's not
bothering you
if the coconut does not seem to be
turning into something because I don't
want to keep around yeah does it smell
does it smell like coconut cheese and
keep the coconut definitely the cocoa
it's more than one coconut yeah no where
do you get why real question can you get
coconuts in the grocery store I have no
idea my question is why I know that's
the real question right for me what you
can't just is the coconut symbolizes it
it may be an allegory for the baby Jesus
of course it is feed of yeah God I don't
buy full of the nutrients milk of his
forgiveness how do you anymore somebody
being my sin we have a with the nutrient
milk of sin we have a tradition we keep
a coconut of the tree it dates back to
my grandmother I'm not gonna tell you
the thing else about it though explain
do you even know yes plain maybe it's
just but it's not it's not a super old
coconut it's just a fairly oh no it's
not like her grandmother's coconut is
coconut has been around I don't know
maybe it got lost in the war sometimes
you have to leave your important things
behind it's true it's been a long time
oh you know maybe a third what happened
to the open they had refugee crises and
they had to leave Hawaii yeah all right
wherever else they had coconut oh well I
bet uh uh I bet everybody have their own
I think everybody should have something
special that's their own Christmas
tradition sure I don't really feel like
we have one of those us yeah
just shoveling the walk feeling
nauseated which I have for for the
entire time since Christmas still going
they'll go I'm tell feel
nauseated mom I have this collection of
Santa's that putting together but it's
not that's not like a specific to me
kind of thing I have like the put
together the metal earth laser-cut thing
and if you're doing fear for you years
like ha Christmas morning and get to put
together a metal or Captain Bob I get to
be frustrated for three days give myself
a headache
it's angers hurt like I'm just sitting
there and I'm just like oh are you
serious
know if you don't know what I'm talking
about Google metal Earth these tiny tiny
altars they're so cool and and I just
scream for a day and Catherine's like
this is really what you want to be doing
and I'm like yes exactly this is called
fun this is the best thing because it's
you know you work hard at it it's
challenged but then the end you've done
the thing yes there's that thing you did
and you never looked in that look right
at it never perfect no but it it is the
thing you did there's the thing you did
we got another question
this one's from Megan who asks dear Hank
and John as I was out on the town with a
few friends for New Year's we came up
with the question is there a specific
name for the clothes
someone is buried in we tried googling
it but to no avail
I'm a huge fan of the podcast and when
we couldn't find an answer we knew that
you were the ones to turn to please
answer my question Megan well you came
to the right place really yeah do you
know what what burial clothes are called
um should i well there's a thing called
the burial shroud yes don't use that any
may know about the shroud so there's
there's a shroud and there's there's
also I think what else do they call it
there it's like the winding cloth so
it's like a big long sheet they go ride
around the body sure so we don't have
those anymore we have regular clothes
mostly that we bury people in yeah and
that is called the grave clothes that's
the actual technical term for the
clothes that you wear when you go into
the grave or or it doesn't matter you
don't have to be being buried if you're
cremated in them they're also still your
grave clothes my question is because I
we've haven't talked about this yeah if
you die what do you want you're very
close to be if I die
yeah like who's the thing is I feel like
if I died you guys would hate you
something that have to get me a new suit
because don't bury me in that one that I
have it's not very nice it's too big ok
I think I think it's too big for me but
boy I can't seem to muster any any real
care right but about that specific just
like whatever you freaky the water would
dress me up as if you Princess Leia
not the bikini ok that's the first
thought that's a bad idea the white
first outfit that she comes out and the
white the Princess Leia outfit sort of a
shroud II like the Slave Leia outfit you
got it
um but not really I mean I don't have I
don't I don't care just unity comfy do
you want to wear like a hoodie I'm
jeanna pants it doesn't matter
item you're gonna burn up my body anyway
so gives you don't burn yourself put me
in something that when it burns it
causes the least amount of do you want
any oh my god any items a book or don't
do things at my funeral for me right
right do things at my funeral for the
people that are that are still around
right well sometimes I feel like it's
good to have specific instructions so
people don't get into arguments and the
next in the next 10 years being like I
can't believe you buried a Dan at ok um
that is a good point that is the only
reason that I would care about these
things yeah um
alright well let's talk about it in like
30 years well I mean sure how old am i
30 years maybe 20 who knows who knows
real tired these days Hank ok they got
another question for us gathered Oh God
this question is from Celeste who asks
dear brothers I am 13 and cats sit in my
building regularly for my neighbor she
has forgotten to pay me for my last
couple of gigs but made it up this
weekend I noticed that she gave me $20
more than I am do hmm I would normally
give it back to her but it came in a
holiday card and maybe a little bonus
because of this season should I keep the
money butternut squash and flamingos
Celeste in NYC okay you can't just put
two weird things together that's like
pumpkins and penguins I get it squash
and it's bird sure squashes and birds so
III have a concern which is that this is
100% present and 0% payment for previous
gigs
yes exactly I'm wondering if there was
actually an arrangement to be paid for
cat sitting ever oh really
front by this neighbor I mean a lot of
times it seems like some sometimes they
were paid and sometimes they way that
does seem like but it I think that um I
mean it's difficult because you're 13 so
it's like you're not really an employee
but you're doing a favor for someone you
should get you should get paid if it's
the thing that they said you're gonna
pay you for yes that that is not as
number one you should probably if you're
doing this regularly and you're doing a
good job
mm-hmm make sure that you get paid every
time yeah but this is this is definitely
not back payment for missed previous you
don't think you don't think it's
possible that it's back payment plus a
little extra because I feel like there's
a chance that it's one a chance that
it's the other the chance that it's back
payment plus a little extra a chance
that's a hundred percent present I think
it's present you think it's a hundred
percent present yeah because I mean but
it may be present with guilt associated
right because they realize they forgot
to pay you those other times maybe well
yeah I mean the only way to settle it is
to ask but I will say that it's
definitely not accidental extra money
exactly you got a bonus yeah don't don't
don't give it back but make sure that
you but make sure that also somebody has
an extra like give like puts an extra 20
bucks in your let the tip
yeah they didn't do that accidentally
yeah but I wouldn't I would have before
this happened been like mrs.
Stephanopoulos Stephanopoulos let's try
to go with the name that was not
definitely one particular nationality
and totally did that I didn't want to be
like the cheap Greek in your building oh
my god that's not even what I was going
I know it's also it's also not even a
Greek stereotype I don't think III
wouldn't I I wouldn't know the only
stereotype I have about Greek people is
that they make excellent Greek food no
is that good
yep yeah they seem very nice and they're
having a little bit of trouble with
their debt that's what I know about
Greek people
so yes you got to be like missus lady uh
pay me like you gotta you gotta have it
come up before Christmas time and then
suddenly yeah but you're thirteen I
understand that might be weird sorry but
if you don't do the thing you should
bring it up maybe just maybe just leave
a note you know in your building maybe
if you just happen to see her or him
said lady I think uh yeah I think you
said I think it's a just neighbor
misgender I just deleted the question
okay yeah well I there's too many things
in the document so I had to have to
anyway um yeah Celeste I think this is
definitely not an accident so don't give
it back and in the future maybe just a
little reminder yeah when you schedule
these things yeah okay so three three
days that'll be that'll be however much
it is per day yeah you know just just a
reminder mm-hmm
or like when you leave a note at the end
of the sitting if there wasn't money
mm-hm when you just be like you can drop
that off at my apartment anytime yep
this is my apartment number yeah here's
my phone number
under the door I'll fall down or
whatever you know I I can use that cash
yeah pokemon cards I really love noodles
noodles the cat really sweet cat yeah
yeah
where's my 20 oh hey we got another one
we've gotta go we gotta move on that
question it's not even in the dock
anymore Juliana asks dear Hank and John
what is the best way to be empathetic to
your toward your partner's insecurities
I love my partner very much but I find
myself often not being able to relate in
the way that they need and I say the
wrong thing I want to protect their
feelings and I also want it to be honest
it's a good question for Kathryn and I
answer because we're different that's
real hard
we're different folk sure sure sure sure
empathetic towards your partner's
insecurities hmm it sounds a little bit
Oh sounds um it almost sounds
condescending just in the question edgy
yeah but but I understand what you're
trying to say and that's yes and you
have and you have to think about these
things and consider it well yes which I
think you're doing a good job of doing
already what is the best way to be
empathetic toward your partners and
securities how are you empathetic toward
my insecurities I don't know I'm trying
to think of any I gotta say I'm really
often not because I feel like they're
you I need some yeah make a couple extra
insecurities because it doesn't have
enough I mean the thing that I that is
coming to mind right now is just like
your competitiveness with John I'm not
competitive with John in his success
well okay well there you go just bring
them up acknowledge them no oh yeah
acknowledging them yeah without judgment
obviously and allowing yeah I have a
hard time doing this but I like I want
to create good situations and spaces for
you to talk
things yeah yeah and just like that it
like get you speaking words right
because and and in addition to that not
always needing to offer a solution right
just just have them having the
conversation have like it's happening
yes and and like you're talking about it
I'm understanding it you're
understanding it it's out there now
uh-huh because I think like like you're
not you don't have to like fixing no no
you noticed understanding yeah you don't
have to be like okay great what do we do
about this problem you have right
because that's not mmm that's not your
role no not really
probably you shouldn't have to be your
partner's therapists no I think that
there is like therapeutic action to
conversing sure yes it can be very
helpful for everyone involved to have a
good Mike Hardy conversation and I think
we don't have enough of those
opportunities these days and there's a
lot of like like feeling isolated and
lonely now another YouTube video or
something yeah all right creating some
space and whether that's like going out
to dinner and being like in a place
where you're not gonna feel okay looking
at your phone or if it's at a scheduled
time where you be like ok we're gonna
have like next Tuesday Kathryn can we
have some like phone free conversation
yeah and not have that be like because
like because there's a big problem
happening in our life or because there's
a money thing or just being like we're
like scheduling this for the future
creating space for those conversations
to happen mm-hmm
not trying to solve yeah problems as you
see them maybe just reframing like even
just how your king cannot as problems
but as challenges I don't know what I'm
trying to say yeah like I think I think
you say you love this person yeah I
think reframing from problems to just
understanding like in the way that mr.
Darcy
loves Elizabeth Bennet because of all
her quirks right not in spite of them
and so like like loving a person in that
way that that like encompasses all of
their like the things that you kind of
don't like about them and I guess like
you have to understand that they're
gonna be things that you don't like
about your pick your partner yeah yeah
and and but so you say you also want to
be honest
yeah that's there's a little bit of a
worrying mm-hmm word because why like
what is it about being honest that you
feel you need mm-hmm to express some
like is it because you want them to
change
mm-hmm is it because you are worried
about how these are how this is
impacting them yeah you know like is it
on an unhealthy behavior that you're
trying to get them to recognize right
what is the honesty yeah because it or
is it just because you're like I don't
like this about you yeah
and so and so you gotta look into that
yeah and it's sometimes I have found in
my life you can't just walk away and
keep talking okay you can walk away
sometimes I have found in my life that
what I see is someone's problem is just
them living and the way that they want
to live
that is different than the way I want to
live and I'm like you're not productive
and it's like well yeah Hank you freeze
that highly right like that is the thing
that I'm into right but it's maybe not
but not for it's not for everybody yeah
not the same for Katherine oh yeah no I
mean I do stuff I don't know it's not
like not like the way that I get really
obsessed with like maximizing
productivity right and and then like if
i if I'm then like you know if I have
this like sort of hang up on one
particular like aspect of like how to
live a good life alright and I'm not but
I'm not hung up on some other stuff like
that doesn't mean
that you aren't living you are perfect
you know your best life yeah just
because you don't have all the exact
same right anchors that I do yeah I mean
the thing is you are living with a
person who is not you mm-hmm Giuliana
yep this is you gotta just but you know
if it's unhealthy right and if it's like
yeah it's if it's something that's
making you uncomfortable like then then
you know it's a challenge that that is a
challenge that you either have to work
through and let and have them recognize
the way that it's affecting you and if
they aren't willing to move beyond
having an effect on you that's making
this relationship unpleasant for you
then you might also find comfort in
solitude right yeah anyway yeah yes this
is an advice podcast by two extremely
unqualified people dubious I'm gonna
answer a question that is less important
this was from Carrie who asks dear Hank
and John I was sitting at my desk at
work the other day when a highly
distressing thought occurred to me I
know my cat's name he clearly knows his
own name mm-hmm but does he know mine
you know I live alone and don't
generally refer to myself in third
person so it's not like he hears it that
often
what does my cat think I am am I just an
anonymous conglomeration of smells and
features to his brain
well okay it's not that you can't knows
his name either anyway but it's just
like that's a word that you say that
means hey you yeah I don't know
attention right like if that was my
cat's name my cat's thing would beeps
yeah that's that's what the thing that
works most of the time yeah it's or
kitty or your cameo in a specific tone
of voice yes the other thing that I'm
worried about
Carrie is that you think that you are
your name yeah and also but if your
if your cat doesn't know your name then
your cat doesn't you kept like who does
I can't think I a does my cat think that
I'm some other person because like
because I'm not Carrie no your cat
thinks you're you yeah
just doesn't think of you as your name
by your name
thank you as that thing that lives in my
house that very large cat without on the
fur who provides me with food yeah mommy
can't that's how your cat thinks yeah I
don't know I I think that yeah it's a
it's a funny question I do they did
think it was funny um am I just an
anonymous conglomeration of smells and
features to his brain isn't that what we
all are to everyone
we're just anonymous conglomerations of
smells and features to each other's
brains well as humans we are extremely
into naming things we do I mean
categorizing them categorize your oh boy
dad joke and go fooling back so sorry so
yeah you know you can't doesn't think
like you think you can't does not think
like you think it's hard to figure out
exactly how yes right
cats the boy cats right I was just
watching that video of all the cats
getting brain freeze again this morning
what cats getting brain freeze that's so
good they're like licking real cold
yogurt or something and they all just
have this moment where they freeze and
spaz yeah pretty much
like that and then at the very end
there's just this one and he's like yes
it makes the noise there's a whole
compilation of it yeah this is the one
sister one this ah they don't like it
they don't like it we'll put this up on
the patreon they don't like it they do
that thing where you where you're like I
got it pause and like clench all my
muscles mhm
well this is happening anyway anyway
that's right that's right to the advice
here's another question I don't know if
you can count this as advice but
anonymous asks you're Hank and John why
are commercials so loud or is it just me
it's not just you commercials are
allowed because they want you to pay
attention no I'm gonna be completely
honest here commercials are loud because
television is ending and they're trying
to sit - trying to squeeze every last
cent out of it before it implodes it's
the same reason that when you watch
television now all of the commercials
are terrible for things that are
embarrassing and probably just like
often times fraud television I watched
some TV the other day there's so many ad
is like 300 ads per minute it's so much
I can't handle it and they're only for
people like over 60 yes who still watch
TV the way that TV used to be that's why
they're so loud because a lot of these
people are hard of hearing and it's like
hey hey you need this button to push
when you fall down you need this button
oh man get this button right I don't
like I really wish we could have based
our content ecosystems on something
except ads yeah I mean and this is
say that that like content is ending no
no this is the way that it has existed
right and to be clear I don't watch TV
at the moments when like good
advertisements are happening like I
don't watch The Walking Dead like I'm
sure if I watched an episode of The
Walking Dead or some other like the
Superbowl ad supported piece of content
that lots of people actually watch but I
usually want to watch TV it's like it's
like I'm stuck in a hotel or something
right right right right right right yes
yes and it's nighttime and I'm and I'm
sad and alone and looking for connection
and it's just like here is a here is the
world's top ten air disasters right and
it's like you know local yeah that it's
not relevant to you and also has just a
very low production value which is fine
whatever not everybody can get
rhettandlink to make them a commercial
no I got a response here it's not a
question it's Amanda who asks dear Hank
and John excuse me John this question is
for John I'm gonna take it though oh
that's excellent because he's not here
to defend himself but you expressed in
the recent pod recording at nerdcon
stories that you aren't allowed to name
your dogs similarly to the names of your
family remembers I would just like to
point out to you that your dog's name is
Willy and your brother's name is William
would you maybe like to rethink your
terrible mistake he got called out so
Willie's name is Wilson not William yes
it's fireball Wilson Roberts call him
yes that Willie but but when every what
if you were looking at baby names yeah
William was always gonna be high on the
list because my name is William yeah and
my grandfather's name is William and I
like and I I'm not saying that Willie's
existence affected that but yes
no that didn't is most of that I didn't
want to name my son directly after me
yeah that seems like a weird thing to do
but anyway we just wanted to let
everybody know that John was a hypocrite
and made a terrible terrible mistake in
his dog naming or and/or in his
criticism of other people's dog naming
so it's one of those two things
definitely one of those too yeah I mean
yeah anyway that the situation as you
said is a little more complicated than
Ana is it oh who asked that question
thanks Miranda thinks it was but also
don't name your animals after your
children or you know unless that's what
they want to call them I guess yeah it's
fine do whatever you want to do right
sure yeah there you go
there's that's the right answer it's a
pet I say they're not gonna mail it
after some food just like I say there
are an infinite number of pet names
available so don't go for a human pet
name because you could name the pet
panettone and it would be great sure
yeah I'm taking great that's a great
name it could name it Oreo yeah Oh pears
pears you could name it noodle like that
cat earlier in the podcast you could
name it
Gatorade that's fine all pet names are
our pet names like you can glitter
that's fine sure yep to buy for sure why
not
absolutely yeah it ought to be lamps
yeah yeah infinite number of names
available to pets yeah I mean so so why
give it a buy give it a human name
that's how I feel but also do whatever
you want to do I have an Amazon employee
who has written into me okay I would
like to hear about this so in our last
episode of the pod John and I
intentionally tried to activate
people people's right right yes and
their Google homes and Richard says I am
a computer science student in a
university the same time where Amazon is
so it's not an Amazon at the same time
where Alexa was developed naturally at
some point I came into contact with an
employee who was on the Alexa team they
were telling me a fun story that during
Amazon's big Superbowl commercial when
Alec Baldwin and company asked Alexa to
do a thing there was a massive spike in
Alexa queries do two peoples Alexa's in
their living rooms being triggered by
the TV yeah they also said that this
wasn't a surprise to the Amazon
employees as someone had actually
thought of this beforehand and they had
provide and they had provided extra
servers and employees to deal with the
spike so it is a known phenomenon and
the question is can I buy a television
commercial and and steal a bunch of
stuff from people by activating their
Alexa's and making them send me things
yeah with my very loud television
commercial that I put on some television
show Mel Hank green yeah 900 Snickers
Snickers I was thinking something more
valuable and easy to sell just like like
can you get Alexa to send me it's so
easy to to buy gold on Amazon right just
send a small amount of gold send it to
this address and then I'll just I'll get
it and I'll run away and I'll finally
have no I'm worried I'm worried about
Alexa hacking and some weird yet
something's gonna like walk up to your
back window with and like scream at the
Alexa to make it do stuff yeah and you
should be I don't feel good about those
things we have one I know we got it for
free Google sent it to us sure they were
like you're a youtuber here have the
Google home okay Google if you want to
say some of the podcast
she likes her style yeah she said she
said I like your style
oh okay guys like your style - honey I
don't like her okay Google doesn't have
a name yeah she's like you can call me
Google assistant and she just said yes
Google again but like yeah but Esther
what her name was and she said yeah yeah
we couldn't wouldn't let us rename yeah
but there's probably complicated reasons
why that is why they can't rename it
easily but I don't like I would much
prefer to call it the name of a thing
yeah instead of having to say ok Google
ok Google ok Google ok Google I'm just
like oh god I understand I realized that
you want me to say Google of Oregon
launched but I don't want to I don't I
don't know no please just call her pizza
lady lady pizza lady pizza can you play
me the news I don't say that everybody
should be able to rename their their
Google homes anything they want but I
think that you can it should at least be
able to choose between OK Google and
lady pizza all right ok
give us another question is from Sarah
who asks dear Hank and John I was
recently watching of Laura's video
entitled why are fewer people studying
science and engineering and I started to
feel guilty I have a stem degree I have
a BS in mathematics post college I
accepted a job at an industrial supply
company and while I do not use my degree
every day I do use the problem-solving
skills my degree has taught me but I
still feel guilty have I turned my back
on my fellow stem comrades should I get
a job utilizing my degree more I'm happy
where I am but I still feel like I'm not
living up to my potential that I am
doing disservice to the world because it
taught me all of this skill and I chose
another path and he dubious advice would
be welcomed not Orion Sarah
don't be silly it's so it's so
interesting what we can get caught up on
and and feel guilty about and get like
feel like we have this obligation to
like what we used to want or what the
world needs but like obviously the world
needs someone to do your job or no one
would pay you to do it and if you like
it then that's great
and also you probably as you say use
your problem-solving skills but you
probably also use all kinds of the
skills that you learn in your stem
degree and probably that degree helped
you get that job in a number of
different ways so yeah if you have a
also if you have like an abstract
mathematics degree you're not gonna get
a job doing abstract mathematics unless
you're teaching it like I
oh wow we're having though we're
Blizzard outside no is very light so
it's blowing around yeah so I don't feel
guilty and also I I'm worried now that
that video is making people feel like
they should feel like less of an
American or less of a person if they
didn't study or work in those fields the
reason that a lot of people are trying
to get their people into those degrees
is because it helps you get a job yeah
if you got a job then good job you did
it yeah you achieve the goal it's also
because of course like you can you can
solve problems and make the world a
better place but you can do that at all
kinds of different jobs you do that one
year a writer you do that yeah yeah
service like you like people the world
though yeah you do that one you like are
helping people whether that's making
them food or making them healthier or
taking care of them when they're old
like all of the jobs we do are solving
problems for people and and I am I'm
loathe to think that people think that I
don't think that right yeah it's not
like you
or you're like this is a better job than
that other job yeah
though I think there are a lot of people
who feel that way and and you know
there's that there's there certainly are
that pressure but so I see Catherine
that you are what didn't that episode
not answering that question while you're
answering that question yes I was a
little quiet while you're answering that
question because it was trying to find
some interesting news from the AFC
Wimbledon it does seem like it's time to
do that already it does well yeah well
I'm just gonna watch these cats getting
brain freezes while you do that okay
watch the brain freeze video though okay
so what happened with AFC Wimbledon I
don't know but I'll read you the most
recent article on the AFC Wimbledon news
okay do that
David Fitzpatrick played a starring role
on New Year's Day for Torquay United the
name of that place no that's fine
but they're not real places ever in it I
mean I even know where it is but I
couldn't tell you how to say it I'm I'm
surrogate John and his thing is
mispronouncing words wrong
I mean mr. guinea mispronounce something
wrong mispronouncing them um anyway oh
here it is David Pitts Fitzpatrick
apparently a sports player sports player
for the sports team toured away United
oh yeah played a starring role on New
Year's Day for torque Turkey United in a
10 goal thriller at national league
winning chasers Forest Green Rovers so
many words in there that I do not
comprehend the Dons winger scored and
set up four goals in the game of the day
that's a lot at five five draw at the
new lon
which is apparently the name of the
stadium because
I think this article is for free kick
from Fitzpatrick had to put Torquay five
to three up before for a screen hit back
to salvage a share of the Spoils
meanwhile George Oakley also continued
his prolific season after returning from
serious injury with another goal during
his loan spell at Welling United why are
these characters being loaned to other
teams I don't understand oh this is a
he's not even playing for the woman yes
T you're currently on loan to other
teams they're doing quite well sure
here's some players that are playing for
little Timmy they're doing good at other
places I gotta say English football is a
it is dense dense there's it's difficult
to penetrate the yes and we will we will
never really know we will never truly
understand now well in Mars news thanks
for that weird update on Wimbledon
Katherine sorry they lost a couple games
that's what I heard and some of their
players did well on other teams good job
in Mars news China's going to Mars and
by going to I mean not their bodies by
2020 they say China is aiming to have a
robotic mission to Mars by 2020 which is
quite soon it's 20 its 2017 now
officially so that's just three years
from now that does not leave a ton of
time for planning this but that's
exciting and they also want to be
ascending robot to the Dark Side of the
Moon in 2018 they've been doing a bunch
of that that's more punch Marcus I heard
about this news and it made me curious
how collaborative all of these plans are
like do they follow the same
standardized practices of like making
sure there isn't
the earth stuff information biology yeah
on these things
do you know unlike what's the goal do
they share what they find there or are
they going to be super proprietary about
it like um yeah I'm just curious about
how that works with because I know that
there are like giant there's there's
been Chinese people on the International
Space Station yeah so well back in the
day everything was open and it was very
collaborative like like all the stuff we
had they could have Russia could have
anybody could have in terms of what NASA
was doing when I was back in the day
until 2011 when the Congress was like
stop sharing our military secrets China
basically okay but like even but how
about back before that day when there
was like space race and stuff well yeah
no I'm talking about the 60s okay so
yeah so so the during the like you know
Space Shuttle era you know eighties
nineties 2000s there was a lot of
collaboration and a lot of like the idea
of being like we can work together in
these scientific enterprises and it will
you know even when we are argue about
all of us it'll benefit all of us yeah
the scientific data has still been
shared so when we go to Mars and like
all the stuff that curiosity gets like
it wasn't controlled by the US
government
okay the data can be like what what
tends to happen is like an entry data is
shared but technology is not is that
you're saying yes data will often come
through the people who design the
instrument so curiosity will have like
25 different things on it and so that
the data will come through
whoever like created the instrument and
knows how to take the data in and but
then hope like the idea is that then
anybody can look at that data and do
research with it right and so hopefully
that will happen yeah in opposite
directions as well and we can compare
and contrast and probably we will but it
is not so
much the you know like the designs for
how to build these things though we do
still share that information with some
of that information with Russia and with
Europe and okay I think to some extent
with China to UM just to increase the
ability but there's like a lot more
concern now that like China is trying to
build systems that might be bad for our
national security
whatever that means is not something
that I find myself to be tremendously
concerned about but others have you know
Congress and stuff so Katherine what did
we learn today um we are tired yeah it
is the new year all right
I'm red ray well in 2017
and beneficial of probiotics to you all
and of course we're just gonna have two
things we learned so we learned that and
we also learned that time is decided by
people in Geneva Switzerland
I sure they make that call those folks
those folks and if one day they decided
to just change time completely just add
15 minutes and mess us all up what would
we even do go along with the dudes I
think we'd rebelled no I think we'd
storm the castle no we'd go yep yeah we
also learned that you got doesn't need
to know your name it loves you anyway
yeah or whatever it is that cats feel
and of course we learned that television
commercials are so loud because my
brother John is a hypocrite we I think
it got my wires crossed on that one well
Katherine thank you for joining me on
this podcast thank you for going to get
my baby he's not crying anymore
good job
isn't is happy to be here thank you for
having him on the podcast for this last
[Music]
we spoke too soon this podcast is
supported by our patrons at patreon.com
slash dear Hank and John you can send us
questions at Hank and John at gmail.com
or with the hashtag dear Hank and John
on Twitter we are here to answer your
questions and give you dubious advice as
always this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins and Victoria
bonjourno Jornal helped us pick out
questions yes and gunnarolla does our
theme music and I don't think I forgot
anybody I don't think so either and so
as they say in our hometown don't forget
to be awesome
[Music]